welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday
yesterday the Minneapolis Police
Department from which four officers were
fired in the death of George Floyd
announced it was banning the use of
chokehold and neck restraints all week
we've seen protesters around the country
calling for a change in police practices
and an end to the bias that leads to
racial profiling some are hoping this
could be a watershed moment in that long
battle standard operating procedure is
under fire as protesters demand police
reform across the country to stand up in
charges made and say get your knees
eulogizing George Floyd on Thursday the
Reverend Al Sharpton called this a
defining new chapter in the decades-long
civil rights movement another area we
had to fight Jim Crow another era we
dealt with voting rights this is the era
to deal with policing and criminal
justice
yet the recent deaths of unarmed black
Americans from a mod are buried -
Brianna Taylor and George Floyd are a
black eye on the road to reform I was
dismayed and I felt what about the
progress that we have been seeing over
the years since Ferguson a lot of our
work is going to involve local police
chiefs George Mason University professor
Laurie Robinson was a co-chair of
President Obama's Task Force on 21st
century policing created following the
unrest over the 2014 death of Michael
Brown in Ferguson Missouri the task
force focused on six pillars of policing
including building trust and legitimacy
policy and oversight officer training
and education and officer safety and
wellness is the answer in the state or
at the local level over 30 states have
passed different measures to address
problems in the area of policing
different policing reforms and numerous
localities in their police departments
have adopted
measures much more clearly needs to be
done but the state and local side is
where action has to occur but that takes
recognizing that reform is needed
policing is unfair frank baum gartner
wrote the 2018 book suspects citizens
analyzing 22 million traffic stops over
20 years in just one state North
Carolina we spoke following the high
profile deaths of volando Castile in
Minnesota Walter Scott in South Carolina
and Sandra bland in Texas all died after
being pulled over by police it made me
realize that people are not making stuff
up the data is clear it shows in North
Carolina that african-americans had been
stopped twice as often as white drivers
and while they were four times more
likely to be searched were actually less
likely to be issued a ticket
the study also highlighted that whites
were more likely to be found with
contraband than blacks or Hispanics so
essentially if you are underrepresented
in someone's mind as a participating
citizen your rights are up for grabs
you're viewed as a criminal suspect that
data was undeniable to Chapel Hill
Police Chief Chris blue is it inherent
bias I'm not sure I know what it is
police agencies are trying to think very
hard about what policies and
interventions they can put in place that
might help balance out some of those
disparities that were found in the work
Blue has implemented reforms in his own
department de-emphasizing the low-level
kind of traffic enforcement that the
numbers really show have a
disproportionate effect on communities
of color hasn't really had an impact on
your ability to fight crime no I don't
think so
for years citations and arrests were a
measure of success what we thought was
effective policing was maybe not
achieving the things we thought it would
still it's an uphill battle as chief
blue acknowledged in a video he posted
Monday on Facebook we must start saying
loudly that we won't continue to
tolerate the behaviors of officers or
agencies that damage what we've built
not all law enforcement officers agree
and the handcuffing and oppression of
police was despicable
last year lieutenant Bob Kroll of the
Minneapolis Police Officers Federation
praised the Trump administration's
hands-off approach to oversight this was
incredible bipartisan support while the
President signed the first-step Act in
2018 a landmark prison and sentencing
reform law that released more than 3,100
nonviolent offenders serving time in
federal prisons please don't be too nice
he's voiced his commitment to law and
order something both he and his chief
law enforcement officer Attorney General
William Barr agree on if communities
don't give that support and respect they
may find themselves without the police
protection they need that hasn't stopped
millions from pouring into the streets
from the nation's capital to New York
City
to North Dakota and while there have
been skirmishes and animosity remains
some police officers have joined in the
marches even taking a knee are you
hopeful that in one to five years from
now we won't see this happening all over
again it's enormous
an enormous tragedy but I am hopeful
that the attention to it will cause
enough people to focus on the need for
action and that is Laurie Robinson's
point the reforms in both cities big and
small are taking place it just needs to
be taking place more often in more
places yeah Michelle there's something
to hearing that same messaging that it
has to take place on the local level you
have to admit that you have issues in
order to change them so important in
such a great piece